[Music]
there's 0.0 down nft culture is here for
the rest of my entire life
you got your perspective
i just want to be happy don't you want
to be happy
so happy to be here jacob and uh hi
everybody who's watching uh
i i said this once in 2009 we're at a
social media conference
if you are watching this right now for
the majority of people
a lot of this is old news and this has
probably been a four or five year thing
but let there be no confusion you are
disproportionately ahead of the game and
i hope there's a lot of happiness and
challenges and interests with that and
so i'm very honored to be here and thank
you for having me
thank you yeah i mean maybe that's a
good place to start we'd love to kind of
maybe learn a little bit more about sort
of you know how long you've been
thinking about the space you know i know
you've been talking a lot about nfts
recently on
on your podcast on on youtube and
everything um i mean when was your
interest peaked like when did you kind
of take a look
uh the journey is in 2016
a gentleman by name of aaron battalion
and a tremendous technologist cto
of living social and just somebody i'd
really admire of
being an incredible nerd aka really
technically sound
but in intuitive consumer behavior which
is obviously where i live
and so we would always have these jam
sessions at south by southwest and he i
bought
bitcoin in 14 and this was 16 south by
and he started explaining ethereum to me
and my brain went into oh this is
interesting this is
platform not currency and i'm like i'm
not a financier like i to this day
get you know i'm all about nft life and
all my friends that want me to get
excited about
currencies i get it and i'm like i don't
to me it's not like doge this or or
bitcoin this or altcoin to the
moon that like it's just not as
interesting to me the same reason i
don't
buy a lot of currencies or trade or even
stocks on the public market
whereas you know t-shirts and garage
saleing and sports car
like so um and then there's the
the things that will go into deeper
beyond the art and collectibles of nft
life that i think the smart contract
to access and you know uh
touching and and feeling peop things and
experiences you want
um so that access and and
part of of this smart contract so that
excite me so anyway
i you know i bought a bunch of ethereum
and 16
in the same way that i'm looking at vr
today which is
it's looming but it's not prime time
for every person in kansas
that's my game i'm listening and
watching and far
you know i always hate when i enter a
new space at this point in my career
because i have the baggage
of my career and so like i've been
trying to be
very thoughtful about that because i
i get upset when i do something and and
i'm so appreciative i'm humbled that
people ign even this
beautiful intro you know kartik you know
like i understand that i've
done nice and well and have done but i
always think i'm only as good as my new
at-bat and if i come into this space
and i'm a clown and make you know and am
wrong
like it erases everything i've ever done
you're only as good as your next day
right so i've come in
somewhere around february march april
cove
time i'm like wait a minute that nft
thing that i've kind of like
really far away like i know what crypto
kitties are like you know like
like you know i remember looking at that
carefully
um this is starting to happen a little
bit
and then i had a conversation with rohan
from from dapper and top shot and i'm
like
huh and i was in the heat of my sports
card thing
physical it's interesting
and then the fall came and all this time
what really [ __ ] me up was kovid
you know i'm i'm the c you know a lot of
times people forget
for all my loud mouth tactics and
putting out tons of content
i'm the active ceo of a 1300 person
global company that like
and it's client service it's not even
like tech 1300 which is a hell of a lot
easier to manage you're just [ __ ]
getting bombarded by people so
you know navigating being the captain of
really rocky waters
during covid didn't get and then i
decided with michael rubin from fanatics
to do the all-in challenge and we raised
60 million dollars you know to help
people that were hungry during cobid
so i had 0.0 minutes march to
august to what i wanted to do which was
like why is my spidey senses
then the fall came we navigated all that
trauma
and i actually saw offense for vayner x
for
2021 so then i got suckered again
into like putting in extra hours towards
wait a minute i could set up a nice year
for us that's probably a good idea
then it was late late december i feel
like i've got that all accomplished and
i'm like
okay i'm gonna really dig in now and i
started doing real homework
you know you know and i started having
some you know
friends you know that i started like i
started kind of dming quietly
some friends uh kevin rose was
instrumental you know got into a form
the founder of digg.com
truly totally kind of web 2.0 him and i
spent a ton of time
talking about it he was instrumental in
like check out flamingo
check out this i'm going to introduce
you to matt for crypto [ __ ] i'm like
okay like
it just started feeling 2005 to me then
you know i
put out a little piece of content or two
which allowed me with my
you know awareness these days to make
some new friends um
jeff holm holmberg uh you know was a
i just have to give him a shout out kid
that i spent a lot of time talking about
crypto punks and hash masks with and i'm
a learner i'm a
i'm a learner from the bottom up i can't
learn
from like a tech backwards place i have
to go from what are humans doing and
then i go backwards up
i'll learn about level 2 issues by by
understanding like trying to buy
something and being like what the [ __ ]
this gas [ __ ] like that's how i learned
yep and i'm also what my big advantage
is i understand people cold
that's my strength and so
you know the last four months have been
two three four o'clock in the morning
canceling important [ __ ] and taking
another thing
you know you and i met that way like i'm
just taking a meeting you know i'm just
trying to be part of the community
i got excited i started talking then i
was like [ __ ] i have to start talking
way more about
what this moment really is which is the
technologies forever internet
2000 some of the stocks the projects
are incredibly overpriced and there will
be absolutely
in this world's terms ico crashing
culture with and so i've been trying to
put that content out there so people are
being thoughtful
uh i've been learning a lot more about
wrapping and forking and
burning and you know i've really enjoyed
it and so i come to this talk
a incredibly humble and
knowing i'm in the middle of my journey
on the consumer side like what people
are gonna do
i have a flag of conviction that is as
large as anything which is
nft culture is here for the rest of my
entire life there is 0.0 doubt i've only
felt like this twice in my life
1994 when i heard the internet for the
first time
that and i'm like in a day i'm like this
is gonna change my life
and sure enough i'm not building 500
liquor stores for my dad anymore
i'm gonna do this winelibrary.com thing
and and then
friendster myspace it was a little bit
more of a slow burn
but it was definitely one eric castner
my lead developer at winelibrary.com
started making me read techcrunch and i
was like
okay and boom you know youtube he showed
me actually that's not true
there was a single moment eric shows me
youtube and he goes remember four years
ago when you're like can i stream wine
videos on our website
and i told you it was eight trillion
dollars and only two people would watch
and you were like no
i'm like yes he's like well now you can
do it for free on this thing and uh
and in february you know that was in
2005 and then february 2006 i started
wine library tv which really changed my
life because that's what made me use
twitter and facebook to promote that
show
and then i became a practitioner the
only other time i felt that way was
somewhere here in january really only
two months ago
when i did enough homework of like it
went from spidey senses to
my life is going to change and that's
what i fully believe as i sit here
i don't know now i don't know it took me
a decade to learn a lot of tech to talk
the way i talk today about web20 social
the internet i still have plenty to
learn about blockchain
i'm sure i'll say things in the wrong
terminologies and things that nature
those things are irrelevant to me
meaning i have the humility to be
corrected and i love everybody in the
community
i have the patience to learn some of the
real core things i'll need to just just
i always like to be just dangerous
enough so i'm not an idiot
but where i spend 100 of my time and 110
of my time is why are people going to do
this how is this going to affect
somebody who's selling their home can
they put a can they put this on the
ledger and like
make a vig every time this home sold in
the beginning how am i going to launch
my book
wait a minute music artists can do this
wait a minute who's the first providence
i understand that completely that's
everything that's social currency
why do people wear gold watches same
reason they're going to buy this does
the blue check me anything on instagram
it sure does of course can i take a
picture into jpeg who gives a [ __ ] you
don't actually own it and in 13 years
everyone's gonna
actually look to see hones like that's
where i play my game
totally yeah i mean i think it's been
amazing to see you use your platform in
i think a really positive way and then
kind of bring people into this fold
uh and kind of the mindworm that all of
us i think have been thinking about over
the last couple years
um and yeah i think you know you do this
in such a genuine way it comes across
really well
uh so really appreciate you helping out
there jacob
if if everybody really knew me and were
inside my chemicals
if they understood you who you are in
this space
and i consider like this this authentic
crew to me
to me people that were really active
november 1st 2020 back are really part
of a crew that's different
than let's say oh yeah you know february
1st 2021 right
and i've lived that twice in my life
that was when i decided to learn what
the internet was at all
and boy were those tech nerds and then i
met them again
in 2005. they were just different
that early you know people don't
understand what silicon valley looked
like in three four five six like it was
so different than the status that it has
now and i think i i see a lot of those
characters again
in this world now the internet is so
much more mature and accepted mainstream
that the
the juxtaposition of culture pop culture
fame non-fame like it's different but
it's still the same which is
much like a band that goes on to become
pearl jam
that early crew feels a relationship
to the technology and the movement that
must be respected
by people like me that come along and
that is my number one kpi
you saying that to me is much more
important to me than me doing business
well
with this platform so thank you for
saying that no i appreciate it i mean
you know you said you kind of come to
this with a little bit of baggage but i
mean i want to talk about kind of
you know you've had decades of
experience of trading
uh uh trading cards right like uh sports
cards and that kind of thing and
you know collectibles is one of those
pieces on the nft world that
you know is really coming into position
right now i mean top shot is huge you
talked about
uh rohan who's talking later uh in the
summit today about top shot and
dapper in general um i guess kind of
curious about sort of what are your
thoughts about the future of the
collectible piece
and how do you see that sort of coming
on the chain and uh beyond just top
shots right now
and by the way to your point i use
baggage as a slang term to
an incredible gift that i'm given which
is i have notoriety
and respect and and of course that comes
along with razzing and i people think
i'm
sure you know and i get that but for the
most part
what i mean by that is i can't do what i
did in 2005
which was and six which is go to uh
six aparts blog and ask a question or
go on or in 2006 7 being on twitter
like i didn't have the clout reputation
you know personal brand whatever one
wants to call it
and what i mean by that is i when i say
baggage i use it as hey
i think too many people are coming into
space acting like tough guys and tough
gals like they know [ __ ]
and i'm trying to come in like hey i do
have conviction of a couple things i see
comma i'm not trying to come in here
like there's a million people on twitter
that are ogs that can run circles around
me
on the understanding of the technology
of blockchain
you know and crypto and things that
nature where i feel incredibly confident
is what people are gonna do and that's
why i'll go to this part let me go to a
place on collectibles that i have not
heard people talk about
i have a lot of experience in that
thank you i also have a lot of
experience in something else that a lot
of people know me for which is
garage sale right and i actually believe
that the garage sailing part of me
has more insight than even the sports
card version of me and let me explain
[Music]
when i go garage saling i buy things
based on knowing that people have
nostalgia
and pop culture in their blood
and so when i buy a new york city bus
pass that has the world trade center
picture on it i know there's no inherent
real massive value or when i buy
huckleberry hound
in a stuffed animal from knickerbocker
the stuffed animal toy company
for three bucks without even looking at
it on ebay i already know that's forty
fifty dollars
now let me tell you why that story is
important
there's going to be in the advancements
i'm going a little further and beyond
collectibles
what i believe is going to happen i'm
sure given the nature of
where we are in the life cycle of nfts
and who's in this conference
outside of the people that just came in
from my tweet that are probably going
through learning there's a lot of
people here that i think most of the
audience here could be giving the talk
that's just what happens in the
beginning which i respect tremendously
i think everybody knows and is probably
frustrated when everyone's so fixated
just on collectibles and art when we're
talking about
and and by the way i felt this with
e-commerce and social media
people get fixated on the first thing
that makes even any level of
sense to them and then that one of those
things become the conversation i mean
i remember when people talked about the
internet in 95 96 only from the lens
of browsers and search engines yep like
there wasn't
any conversation around like e-commerce
and you know like you know
so because a lot of the early tech
people weren't merchants like i was
so for me the reason i bring up the
garage sale thing is the following
i'll use myself as an example now i'm
going to use a concert
i'm going to use coachella coachella has
bracelets
physical bracelets there's nobody here
watching this right now that's
not confused or confused that in 15 12
7 6 3 years that becomes a token
and it works and then i can't wait to
see like token readers and like while i
got
there's so much fun innovation coming
right for sure you know
you know smart contracts that check off
that you use it like it's gonna be so
cool
right what i know though as garage sale
gary
is seven years later
somebody's gonna buy the first if it
goes on that festival because
becomes coachella right somebody's gonna
buy
that token the same way i would buy the
bracelet at a garage sale for 25 cents
and sell it on ebay for
19. i know that tokens
that are really not collectibles and
arts but representations
of smart contracts are going to have a
secondary market
at a scale that most people haven't made
the chess move connections on
and that is going to be incredible
because that is going to lead to
incredible behavior
at the ip level to try to do
thoughtfulness
for the audience to create that economic
aspect
the economic aspect of that is going to
actually force
leagues musicians festivals things
to actually care more about their custom
right now we're in the golden era jacob
of the people launching projects that
really don't give a [ __ ] about their
audience at all
it's a fast money grab i'm going to draw
something a picture of me or [ __ ]
something that represents me
i'm going to mint 10 000 of them and
because right now
and they're going to make some real
money i mean we've seen some athletes
and somebody
make real money what i know is going to
happen on the other side is
the people that are holding the bag of
that collectible have paid
overpaid so much no different than
pets.com or etoys.com as a stock
that doesn't mean nfts are not going to
be the game changing thing of this
generation
it just means that project is not and
what you're seeing is short-term
transactional behavior right now of
people land grabbing for quick
bags but what they're actually going to
do is hurt their brand
because there's going to be some fans on
the other side that are sad that they
paid three thousand dollars
for ownership of an nft but now the
market says it's 17
aka beanie babies right so totally
so i'm worried about that from for
everybody in this cycle that the person
that's buying it and gets held with the
bag
but i'm actually worried about it
equally for you know they deserve it
because they weren't thoughtful
but it doesn't mean i don't have
compassion to somebody who doesn't
really
there's some people because i've talked
to a bunch of celebrities ip they don't
even realize they're doing bad things
for their audience
they're they they're delusional they
don't understand supply and demand
and where the moment we're in so they
probably in our a lot of them i could
tell i've had the combos they actually
think they're gonna
do well like oh someone's gonna pay 88
000 for this and one day it's going to
be worth 2 million i'm like
first of all your ego is insane
second of all you're very much
misunderstanding what's about to happen
which is
the tokenization of everything do you
know how much supply that is
it's no different than influencers jacob
right influencer marketing i was right
in 2009 when i wrote crush it
and you have the logan pauls and a
charlie demilious but there are
tens of thousands thou hundreds of
thousands and millions of people making
fifty to two hundred thousand dollars a
year being an influencer instead of an
accountant or a gardener
and loving life that's gonna happen with
nft
that's gonna happen with artists that's
gonna happen in a lot of places so
i don't know i think there's a lot of
thoughtfulness that needs to come to the
market
here's my thoughts it is the game
changer for collectibles
arts and pretty much everything in the
world
um there will be incredible love layers
of bubbles and
no different it's like the stock market
was invented
and there'll be plenty of ibms and ges
and
amazons and there'll be plenty of enrons
i mean there will be right
i think we all know personal personal
brands are gonna do things
you know uh i'll give an example this
may be an extreme example but if nfts
have been around for 60 years
somebody might have done incredibly well
with o.j simpson
investing when he was a high school
football player and he put out his nfts
and they were the rookie cards and right
you know in 1991 you look like a genius
you bought something for three dollars
it's now seven
that trillion dollars and then
boom a moment happens like there's
there's a lot of things that are gonna
happen with these nfps but
i think the macro is incredible and i
think when you have people like i'm glad
wilhelm's coming you know what he built
with dapper and flow and
top shot incredible you know i think
he'll add a lot to that conversation but
my big thing is that this that we also
are now at a place where i as a 45 year
old man
would rather wear cool sneakers have
comic books that are graded to 10 own
video games still in the box graded
sports cards wear hoodies wear t-shirts
like the culture is becoming more
collectible
nerd fun like the investment portfolio
of a 45 year old man with my wealth
20 years ago was real estate and stocks
very part
i have more in stock sports cards comic
books toys
nfts that i think is not going to stop
and i think that's going to lead to a
lot more
demand than people are anticipating very
cool
yeah i think that totally makes sense i
mean um just the number of
assets that people are looking at every
day is it's just
it's an order of magnitude more than it
was uh even like 10 years ago right and
i think there's no way that's going to
stop
it's not going to stop and people enjoy
it i enjoy absolutely
my crypto punk more than my tesla stock
i
enjoy my super mario brothers in mint
condition
more than i enjoy my part ownership with
my dad in the real estate at wine
library
i enjoy i enjoy i enjoy
totally that part the mixing of
experiences
and nft smart contracts is going to be
game-changing
absolutely well maybe um a good place to
go here i mean this is going to be a
hackathon
right we're going to have 600 people
building stuff all weekend uh and
hopefully you know 150 or so projects by
sunday
what do you think is missing from the
ecosystem right now or
i'll give you what do you think what do
you want to see built right
first i want everybody who does
something cool to me at garyvee
on twitter because i want to see it
perfect uh
the i want to see real life readers
you know i want to be able to create
nfts that create
hall passes in real life and i want to
be able to
read your wallet physically like a
scanner at
a venue and then it marks off the ledger
that's been used like i want that
i know i know there's the roblox right
now for that like so i'm not
naive enough but like if you're talking
about what's missing that's definitely
coming
that totally um
uh i'm very fascinated about um
the royalties changing based on
you paying a different price just
throwing out some random [ __ ] right now
to get some
thinking going yeah i just think like
when you buy something
could you lower its royalty by paying
more for it up front
like that i think that's kind of cool um
the physical you know i like what the
artifacts people are doing i think the
phys
like i'm a big both and guy i think
there's
right now or like no yeah like they are
like i'm gonna still buy this [ __ ]
and i'm gonna buy a ton like so anybody
who can capture things that create an
ecosystem for
and let me throw an old world problem at
it can somebody create the
operating system for warehouses that can
take on
all the physical versions of the digital
in a world where a lot of people want to
stay anonymous
and don't even want to take ownership of
the physical like like you know i'm
thinking about projects
and yeah custodials thank you you know
that's interesting to me that's like a
boring tech operating system that can
turn old warehouses into something very
valuable that might be fun
and um oh i've got a big one
i actually i need this one i want
somebody to create the communication
layer
i want to be like i'm going to launch a
project i want to be able to talk
every day to my 4 000 people in a deep
in a decentralized way and not have to
force them into a discord or something
like
i'm very like i want to be able to say
right this second
i launched a project i want to say hello
to somebody like
so in wallet communication i think it's
huge
like on the spot community space yeah i
want to just basically be like yo thank
you again for supporting my thing
or yeah all of you right now here's a
link like i want to
support my thing and a lot of good
things are happening
i want people to communicate to them
that's huge for me actually
that one's actually that's my kill that
to me is how you start the social
networks
the reddits the discords of the world in
this game
me talk to the people that bought my
[ __ ]
yeah it's amazing to see the communities
that have formed around crypto punks or
hash marks or everything but that's
because but that's because discord link
on the site do you get it yeah i'm
talking but it could just happen
yeah because don't forget four years
later i'm not following where these
transactions have gone
i might get a little money and then i
know what's happening
but i don't know that jacob sold it to
cardik
and when i want to do something for the
people that own my [ __ ] right now i want
cardik there
not jacob because he went into my
discord but no longer owns it
so that that to me is huge totally
now i can see that this is i have to go
yeah i know you're thank you you're
being sick yeah yeah yeah yeah no no no
no
no
i heard stuff at 1 30. but i just looked
i'm like [ __ ]
by the way anybody who's watching this
please hit me up on twitter to just say
hello i'm i'm
the word i would use is desperate and
honored to be a tiny piece of this
community and want to make more friends
and would love to get anybody's thoughts
on anything
they heard and i definitely want to see
if cardiac thought i said anything
interesting before i leave
you want to jump in kartik no i i want
to say i think
the coolest part of this is that i think
we're finally getting to the piece where
people are thinking about it from what
the interaction looks like uh for the
end consumer of that content
whatever that may be whether that's art
or a way to integrate into a community
and i think this is kind of the right
way to think about it because what
you're talking about is
how do we actually make this valuable
for the end user it doesn't matter how
the tech is set up
correct that's what gets to the millions
that's why i'm going to win just so you
know not because i came in with like
because what made
quote-unquote garyvee was i was a liquor
store
son of a liquor store owner with a 40
person watching youtube show and once i
understood social
immediately i just did what i did in
real life which is
if i can bring more value to them than i
ask for in return
and that is going to be the winning
formula
in the nft because we're talking about
economies and communities here
the end at scale and that's the scale
i mean that's you know that's why i'm
probably getting there's you see the
goosebumps
oh wow look at that isn't that cool no
but really like i
literally called my mom and said nft is
the manifestation of my life's work and
i'm in the prime of my life to take
advantage and to contribute to it do you
know what that feels like to me
like to your point you know how
thoughtfully serious i was taking the
words that came out of my mouth the last
30 minutes we're still early
i have this place in the ecosystem
a different ecosystem web 2 not this web
3 thing but it still carries
and if i can deliver 30 minutes of
thoughtfulness here it can be meaningful
and i'm very honored by that
that is i mean gary love loved the
the no [ __ ] opinion on everything
and then the right
kind of direct view on this and i think
you're i mean i'm just checking out the
chat here there's a lot of comments on
people just agreeing with a lot of
things you've said and
just that's something that means a lot
to me from this community please hit me
up on twitter folks because i have
meetings and i
want to see some things bye everyone
thank you so much thanks so much gary
take care youtube watcher what's up it's
garyvee first of all thank you so much i
hope you're doing super well during
these
times i also want to ask you please
subscribe because my
commitment and exploration of youtube is
about to explode stories polls
more content more engagement more
surprise and delight
this is the time to subscribe i hope you
consider it and i hope i see you soon
you